[Música]
vamos a las noticias de la salud con
Mara Romero sala de maro buenos días
para usted Buenos días Ángela el día de
hoy vamos a tener un tema especial
Porque si viene la salud afecta a todos
los aspectos de nuestra vida también lo
hace la biodiversidad y el mundo está
perdiendo especies animales hay un nuevo
estudio que arroja luz sobre esta crisis
que estamos viviendo sí como muy bien lo
dices veremos en este segmento que esto
no solo afecta a los animales sino que
nos afecta a todos pero vamos a empezar
por el principio por los datos más
básicos es un estudio publicado en
biological reviews está hecho por los
investigadores de Queens University de
belfast y analizaron las tendencias
poblacionales de más de 70.000 especies
de animales en el mundo concluyeron que
el 48% de las especies están perdiendo
población están en decrecimiento que el
49% están estables y que un pequeño 3%
está creciendo su población está
creciendo aquí lo vemos separados porque
tipos de animales estamos hablando vemos
por ejemplo lo que los anfibios y los
pájaros son algunos de los tipos de
animales que tienen mayor parte de
población que está más de especies
digamos que están perdiendo población en
los peces en los insectos el porcentaje
es más parecido entre las especies que
se están manteniendo estables en su
población y las que están perdiendo pero
también es importante destacar en este
color más rojizo el fuerte el Grande
porcentaje que no tenemos datos que son
datos desconocidos Así que esto también
nos dice que tenemos que tener una
cierta precaución con los resultados
pero sin duda también pues estar en
alerta estar en alarma porque hay
muchísimo porcentaje de especies en
todos estos distintos animales que están
perdiendo población sabe que hace unos
años cuando uno viajaba por carreteras
de la región veía muchos insectos
quedaban muchos insectos en los
parabrisas eso ya no pasa eso ya no pasa
de hecho los insectos también es una de
los de los rasgos no de los tipos de
animales que más están desapareciendo
Bueno cuando hablamos de biodiversidad
mar la palabra clave es desequilibrio sí
y así mismo es como lo explican de hecho
los autores del estudio en unas de sus
conclusiones escuchamoslo
nuestros resultados muestran que la
biodiversidad sufre un periodo de
desequilibrio demográfico donde vemos
que el nivel de especies con población
decreciente sobrepasa el de población
creciente por un margen alarmante dada
la velocidad sin precedentes en las que
las actividades humanas degradan el
ambiente el número de especies que se
desploman es mucho mayor que el número
de especies que se adaptan a estos
rápidos cambios
es decir al final Qué significa esto no
que los cambios de población en animales
pueden suceder por muchas cosas los
ecosistemas son pues organismos de
alguna forma vivos van cambiando de algo
siempre pero en este caso no hay
sustitución es decir No no es que se
muestra un cambio que haya unas especies
que desaparecen otras que aumentan no si
no es que estamos perdiendo realmente
especies de animales y poblaciones
muchas de estas especies y es muy
interesante porque en términos de
biodiversidad solemos usar unas escalas
de digamos la lista Roja de especies en
extinción pero claro lo que muestran en
ese caso es casi como una foto de un
momento no Cuántas especies están en
peligro de extinción Cuántas no están en
peligro de extinción gracias a este
estudio vemos más un análisis a través
del tiempo vemos estas tendencias y de
hecho los autores del estudio argumentan
que además antes de llegar a momentos de
extinción precisamente los preceden
estos momentos de declives sostenidos de
la población y que ver cómo van
disminuyendo es un síntoma potencial de
esta posible extinción que va a pasar en
el futuro del algo que de hecho grupos
de científicos han llamado la sexta
extinción masiva en este caso derivada
por la actividad de humana sobre todo
por el cambio climático por la
deforestación por la construcción de
carreteras digamos que por el impacto
general que existen los hábitos
naturales de estos animales los más
radicales dirían que somos una plaga mar
que regiones del mundo sufren más
pérdida de biodiversidad sí a pesar de
que no se puede hacer una generalización
absoluta porque depende un poco de qué
tipos de animales estemos hablando al
menos según este estudio Si vemos que
las principales regiones afectadas son
esas que se encuentran alrededor de los
trópicos en este mapa del mismo estudio
vemos claramente la región amazónica por
ejemplo el sudeste asiático mientras que
en las zonas más temperadas digamos que
están decreciendo menos las especies se
mantienen más más estables es importante
también recordar en este caso que estas
zonas tropicales son en las que menos
datos se tenía al final se recabaron
datos más de países más desarrollados
que suelen estar en el norte global que
de los países tropicales Y eso también
puede sesgar un poco los resultados no y
también pues hablando por ejemplo de
África no el que puede ser que no veamos
tanto problema puede ser por una falta
de resultados puede ser que no harían
falta investigar más en este sentido y
yo me inclino más por la segunda mar
Cuáles son las consecuencias de esta
pérdida de biodiversidad y aquí es donde
el perro se muerde la cola totalmente
Aquí es donde volvemos al inicio de lo
que estabas tú diciendo no que todo nos
afecta la biodiversidad afecta cómo
vamos a vivir en el futuro de formas
insospechadas que muchas veces no
podemos ni prever no el estudio Hace una
cuantificación numérica Mira las piezas
de un engranaje que es mucho más grande
que es el ecosistema no y tenemos que
tener en cuenta que si falla una pieza
se puede tener consecuencias en todo el
resto del mecanismo del de esta
maquinaria tan grande que es el
ecosistema es decir una especie que
desaparezca por ejemplo si es un
Depredador puede hacer que la especie
que depredaba se descontrole Y eso tenga
efectos sobre otros ecosistemas no puede
afectar la calidad del suelo puede
afectar que haya menos vegetación que
haya pues que no sé que no haya buena
calidad del aire por ejemplo no que
falten animales puede hacer que no haya
menos vegetación cuando hay menos
vegetación por ejemplo suceden cosas
como que hay más desprendimientos de
tierra es decir esto es una reacción en
cadena muy grande y que también afecta
mucho a la salud para cerrar un poco en
términos de lo que estamos pues de lo
que nos compete en esta en esta sección
no para comer nutricionalmente no la
disponibilidad de qué tipos de alimentos
habrán para la calidad del agua incluso
para la investigación farmacológica que
muchas veces se basa en los elementos
que se encuentran en la naturaleza
nosotros buscamos Un ejemplo muy
concreto que es el de los polinizadores
por ejemplo las abejas son los más
conocidos Pero hay muchos otros insectos
o animales como los murciélagos vemos
que el 75% de los cultivos del mundo son
parcialmente dependientes de estos
polinizadores y que en toneladas del 35%
de la producción de estos cultivos
dependen también de este trabajo de
polinización que hacen tantos animales
entonces que desaparezcan estos
polinizadores podrá tener un impacto
Incluso en la cantidad de alimentos que
tengamos disponibles nosotros en el
futuro entre muchísimas otras cosas a
propósito el jueves pasado fue el día
mundial de las abejas así que pues otra
fecha para hacer conciencia Muchísimas
gracias a usted porque definitivamente
Necesitamos hablar de estos temas sí
necesitamos recordar que dependemos
mucho más del medio ambiente del que
nosotros creemos y estar agradecidos con
el planeta gracias Mari nos vemos mañana
hasta mañana Ángela